I
EVER HERD.
>> I ASKEDOW ARE YOU?
>> I LIKE MOST RECEIVERS.
>> ARE YOU RECORDING?
I'M A DANG LION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WHAT IS UP, FOOTBALL NERDS.
IT'S ME, CARTOON AARON RODGERS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, I'M SURE
THERE'S A LOT OF OVERREACTION
AFTER OUR WEEK ONE LOSS TO A GUY
WHO HAS NOT PLAYED QUARTERBACK
IN A YEAR.
I WANT TO SAY MY OLD CATCH
PHRASE.
THE ONE YOU GUYS USED TO LIKE.
RELAX.
EVERYONE STOP MEMING ME LOOKING
LIKE A SAD CM PUNK AND JUST
RELAX.
R-E-T-I-R-E -- RELAX.
BE LIKE ME AND RELAX SO MUCH
THAT PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED THAT
YOU DIDN'T TRADE YOUR JOB AS
PROFESSIONAL QUARTERBACK.
LET'S RELAX.
LET'S ASK NICE QUESTIONS.
LET'S BE EMPATHETIC AND BE ZEN
LIKE HOW I AM.
YOU KNOW, I'M PERFECTLY HAPPY
WHERE I'M AT.
I WANT TO GET THAT OUT OF THE
WAY.
EVERYTHING IS GOOD.
EVERYTHING IS NICE.
LET'S ASK THE FIRST QUESTION.
>> AARON!
AARON!
>> YOU.
>> AARON, THIS IS CHRISTOPHER.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> STARTING OFF ON A BAD NOTE,
CHRISTOPHER.
WHAT IS THIS?
THIS IS ME ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS.
YOU GUYS SEEM TO BE LIKE
OBSESSED WITH ME, TALKING ABOUT
AARON RODGERS DRAMA.
ANY CHANCE YOU GET, THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS.
LET'S CALM DOWN.
NEXT QUESTION.
YOU OVER THERE.
>> AARON, NBA JUDGE HERE.
WHY ARE YOU FAKE?
>> WHY ARE YOU FAKE, NBA JUDGE?
DO YOU MEAN WHY AM I A CARTOON
OR A PERSON WHO PRESENTS ONE
THING TO THE MEDIA AND ACTS A
DIFFERENT WAY BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS?
BOTH ARE SUPER RUDE.
YOU KNOW, ALL RIGHT.
NEXT QUESTION.
CAN WE GET A REAL QUESTION?
>> AARON.
>> YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
JOURNALISTS.
I KNOW YOU'RE IN THE "BLEACHER
REPORT" APP.
COME ON, YOU.
>> HI, AARON.
WHY ARE YOU 37 WITH A MAN BUN?
>> OKAY!
WHY AM I 37 WITH A MAN BUN?
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, 37 IS A
NATURAL AGE TO BE SORT OF
LOOKING AT YOUR LIFE AND
THINKING MAYBE I NEED TO TRY
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
MAYBE I NEED TO SEE WHAT IT
LOOKED LIKE IF I SLICKED MY HAIR
BACK REAL TIGHT AND GAVE MYSELF
A BIT OF A MIGRAINE AND SEE IF I
LOOK COOL.
MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE WITH MAN
BUNS ARE IN THEIR LATE 30s,
EARLY 40s.
WE'RE ALL JUST TRYING OUR BEST.
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT QUESTION.
LET'S ASK SOMETHING NICE.
YOU.
>> AARON!
AARON!
>> AARON, ELAM HERE.
WHO IS TO BLAME FOR THE LOSS ON
SUNDAY?
>> I WILL ANSWER THIS, ELAM.
YOU KNOW, ULTIMATELY I TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY.
I'M THE LEADER OF THE TEAM.
I'M THE QUARTERBACK.
I TAKE FULL RESPONSIBILITY.
NOW, WAS IT A LITTLE RIDICULOUS
THAT WE WERE PLAYING IN FLORIDA
IN JACKSONVILLE EVEN THOUGH WE
WERE PLAYING THE NEW ORLEANS
SAINTS?
THEY SEEM TO JUST GET TO PICK
WHERE THEY WANT TO PLAY?
YEAH.
THAT'S QUITE FRANKLY
IRRESPONSIBLE AND UNACCEPTABLE.
AGAIN.
I TAKE FULL RESPONSIBILITY.
I PLAYED LIKE GARBAGE.
I DIDN'T GO OUT THERE AND PLAY
WELL.
SO, YOU KNOW, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THE WHOLE FLORIDA THING, KIND OF
CONFUSING.
WE PLAY THE PACKERS IN TWO
WEEKS, ARE THEY -- OR WE PLAY
THE NINERS RATHER, ARE THEY
GOING TO DECIDE WE PLAY IN THE
MOJAVE DESERT?
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
AGAIN, I TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY.
I WOULD NEVER MAKE AN EXCUSE,
BUT, I BLAME FLORIDA.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> AARON!
AARON!
>> YOU.
>> HI, AARON.
THIS IS ANDREW CODE.
CURIOUS, IS THIS ACTUALLY LIVE?
>> YEAH.
ANDREW, THIS IS ACTUALLY LIVE.
THAT'S WHY -- YOU SUBMITTED A
QUESTION, I'M ANSWERING IT LIVE.
THAT'S HOW THIS WORKS.
THIS IS LIVE.
ANYTHING I SAY IS HAPPENING
CURRENTLY SOMEWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
IT'S HAPPENING FROM GRENARD
HEIGHTS WHERE I LIVE WITH, YOU
KNOW, HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
OTHER FOOTBALL PLAYERS.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> TALK ABOUT MANAGEMENT.
>> I'LL GET TO IT.
YOU.
>> DUDE, YOU GOT BENCHED FOR
JORDAN LOVE.
>> YEAH, I DID GET BENCHED FOR
I KNOW YOU'RE ASKING QUESTIONS
IN THE APP.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE WAY THAT SUNDAY WENT.
I WANT TO SAY, TO GET IT OUT OF
THE WAY, I WAS GLAD TO SEE
JORDAN GET A CHANCE TO PLAY.
TO WATCH HIM GET OUT THERE, YOU
KNOW, NOT DO BETTER THAN ME.
I DIDN'T LOVE TO SEE THAT.
BUT I THINK IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
SOME PEOPLE TO SEE.
YOU KNOW, THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS.
YOU KNOW, LOVE GOT TO PLAY, WAS
JUST AS BAD IF NOT WORSE.
ME AND JORDAN GET ALONG REALLY
WELL.
BUT IT'S WHAT THE GREAT POETS
SAY, YOU KNOW, IF YOU LOVE
SOMETHING, YOU GOT TO SET IT
FREE.
SET LOVE FREE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY.
GET LOVE AWAY.
ACTIVELY PUSH LOVE OUT OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
YOU KNOW, GET LOVE AWAY SO YOU
CAN COMMIT TO A DIFFERENT
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK.
ALL THE OLD AXE YIOMS.
YOU.
>> AARON THIS IS UPTOWN GOAT.
I WANTED TO SAY THAT JAMEIS
BETTER.
>> YEAH, OKAY.
LOOK, UPTOWN GOAT, DID JAMEIS
PLAY BETTER THAN ME THIS
WEEKEND?
YEAH, OF COURSE HE DID.
TOUGH FOR HIM NOT TO.
TREVOR LAWRENCE PLAYED BETTER
THAN ME.
ZACH WILSON ON THE JETS PLAYED
BETTER THAN ME, ALL RIGHT?
IT WAS NOT A TOUGH THING TO DO.
BUT ULTIMATELY, YOU KNOW, I
THINK JAMEIS IS A HELL OF A
COMPETITOR.
I THINK JAMEIS ALSO HAS THREE
MVPs.
NO, SORRY.
SORRY.
THAT'S -- HE DOESN'T.
I DO.
I WON'T MVP LAST YEAR.
WHO'S COUNTING.
JUST ONE GAME.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> AARON!
AARON!
>> YOU.
>> AARON, THE KING 30 HERE.
ARE YOU PLAYING BAD ON PURPOSE
SO GREEN BAY WILL TRADE YOU?
>> OKAY.
THE KING 30, I GUESS, YOU KNOW,
THE OTHER 29 KINGS GOT THERE
FIRST.
ULTIMATELY, NO, I'M NOT.
THIS RUMOR NEEDS TO BE RESTED.
DID I PLAY BAD?
YEAH.
DID I TRY TO PLAY WELL?
WHO'S TO SAY.
BUT ULTIMATELY GREEN BAY WILL
HAVE TO TRADE ME AT THE END OF
THE SEASON IF I WANT TO EITHER
WAY.
I CAN GUARANTEE THAT.
DO I WANT THAT TO HAPPEN?
NO, OBVIOUSLY NOT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE NOT FOCUSING ON THAT.
JUST FOCUSING ON NEXT WEEK.
NO, THE KING 30, I DID NOT PLAY
BAD ON PURPOSE.
I DID NOT TRY TO SABOTAGE THE
TEAM.
I'VE NOT GROWN TO HATE THE
PACKERS AND THIS STUPID UNIFORM
AND EVERYTHING IT STANDS FOR.
I PLAYED WITH MY -- WELL, NOT
WITH MY HEART, BUT, YOU KNOW, I
PLAYED.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> AARON!
>> TELL US SECRETS, AARON.
>> I KNOW YOU GUYS WANT GOSSIP.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
>> HEY, AARON.
THIS IS ORANGE BLUE TRUE.
YOU READY FOR THAT ORANGE AND
BLUE JERSEY?
>> OKAY.
LOOK.
I GUESS WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SAY.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW, I
LOVE, YOU KNOW, GREEN BAY.
I CAN SEE MYSELF LIVING HERE --
NOT FOREVER THAT WOULD BE
RIDICULOUS.
BUT I CAN SEE MYSELF LIVING HERE
FOR, YOU KNOW, AS LONG AS WE
KEEP IMMEDIATELY WINNING SUPER
BOWLS AND THEN IMMEDIATELY
LEAVING IF WE NEVER DON'T.
SO, YOU KNOW, DOES DENVER HAVE A
PROUD TRADITION OF DOING REALLY
WELL AND MAKING THEIR --
REBUILDING THEIR TEAM AROUND A
YOUNG QUARTERBACK AND THEN
IMMEDIATELY TOSSING THAT
QUARTERBACK ASIDE FOR A
LEGENDARY QUARTERBACK?
KIND OF LIKE MYSELF.
YEAH.
I GUESS THEY DO.
AND DOES DENVER SEEM LIKE A
PLACE THAT -- MUCH LIKE GREEN
BAY, IT'S COLD BUT THERE'S
ACTUALLY THINGS TO DO AND
CULTURE AND NIGHT LIFE AND, YOU
KNOW, BIG HOUSES THAT PEOPLE
LIKE ARE IMPRESSED WITH BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE THEY'RE BIG
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE BUT THEY'RE BIG BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, THIS GUY WORKED HARD.
HE LIVES BY A MOUNTAIN.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL?
YEAH.
I'VE SEEN THAT ABOUT DENVER.
REALLY, I'M JUST FOCUSING ON THE
DETROIT LIONS NEXT WEEK.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> COME ON, AARON!
TALK [ BLEEP ]!
>> I WILL TRY TO GIVE YOU ALL
WHAT YOU NEED.
YES, YOU.
>> AARON, KTM SPORTS HERE.
COULD YOU COME SAVE THE GIANTS
FROM DANNY DIMES?
>> HEY, KTM.
I GET IT.
AS I SAID LAST TIME, I'M NOT
JUST GOING TO SAY I'M GOING TO
LEAVE OR THAT I'M LOOKING
AROUND, SHOPPING AROUND OTHER
TEAM
TEAMS.
DID I NOTICE WASHINGTON IS NOW
IN THE NEED OF A QUARTERBACK?
OF COURSE.
DID I LOOK AT HOUSES IN THE
GREATER DMV AREA?
I MIGHT HAVE.
BUT THAT'S JUST ME AS A REAL
ESTATE GUY.
SO COULD I COME SAVE THE GIANTS
FROM DANNY DIMES?
LOOK, YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE A
QUARTERBACK.
YOU HAVE DANNY DIMES.
YOU HAVE A GM, DAVID GETTLEMAN.
LET'S SAY THAT AS LONG AS HE'S
THERE, I DON'T SEE MYSELF THERE.
BUT I GUESS IF THE GIANTS
HYPOTHETICALLY -- THIS IS JUST
KIND OF A SCIENCE FICTION PLOT
LIKE OUT OF ONE OF MY FIANCEE'S
MOVIES.
IF DAVID GETTLEMAN WAS TO LEAVE
NEW YORK AND IF NEW YORK WAS TO
REBUILD ITSELF COMPLETELY AROUND
A FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK LIKE
MYSELF, I GUESS -- COME TO
THINK, I COULD PROBABLY FILM
"JEOPARDY!" THERE.
NEW YORK HAS A GOOD PRODUCTION
SETUP.
SHALENE WOULD LIKE THAT.
MORE FOR HER TO DO THERE.
LET'S TALK SOON.
I LOVE THE PACKERS.
SURE.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> AARON!
AARON!
>> I KNOW PAT McPHEE!
>> YOU, ABSOLUTELY.
>> HEY, AARON.
THIS IS NEXT BIG THING 1998.
YOU MENTIONED "JEOPARDY!."
WHY AREN'T YOU HOSTING
"JEOPARDY!"?
>> LOOK, NEXT BIG THING 1998,
I'M AN NFL QUARTERBACK.
THAT'S WHO I AM.
I'M ALSO A GAME SHOW HOST.
THAT IS ALSO WHO I AM.
FOR A GAME SHOW HOST, I WANT TO
STRESS I PLAYED WELL ON SUNDAY.
STEVE HARVEY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
DESTROYED BY THAT SAME
SECONDARY.
RIGHT NOW I HAVE A LOT OF
FOOTBALL LEFT IN ME.
I'M -- I'M LOVING FOOTBALL.
THIS IS SO MUCH FUP.
TH
FUN.
THIS IS STILL MY FIRST LOVE.
"JEOPARDY!" IS A SCALE OR TWO
AWAY FROM HAPPENING.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> CONTENT!
GIVE US CONTENT!
>> I WILL TRY TO GIVE YOU THAT.
YES, YOU.
>> AARON, VICTOR VASQUEZ HERE.
MESSI OR RONALDO?
>> GOOD QUESTION.
I LIKE THESE QUESTIONS.
I LIKE QUESTIONS ABOUT NOT
INTENSE DETAILS OR MY PERSONAL
LIFE OR CURRENT MOTIVATIONS.
I GUESS I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
RONALDO IS KIND OF LIKE A PRETTY
BOY.
RONALDO IS LIKE THE ATTRACTIVE
GUY THAT EVERYBODY IS IMPRESSED
WITH THAT HE'S STAYED SO
ATTRACTIVE AND KEPT WINNING
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER.
EVERYONE THINKS HE IS SO GOOD
LOOKING.
RONALDO IS SO GREAT.
HE CAN JUST GO TO TAMPA AND
IMMEDIATELY WIN A RING.
MESSI -- PEOPLE FORGET HE'S
SCRUFFY AND REALLY GREAT.
HE'S UNASSUMING.
HE'S SMART AND PLAYS SMART.
HE'S JUST AS GOOD IF NOT BETTER
THAN RONALDO.
RESULTS ARE NOT EVERYTHING.
SO ULTIMATELY I WOULD SAY I'M
KIND OF MORE OF A MESSI GUY THAN
THAT PRETTY BOY WITH HIS MODEL
WIFE OR WHATEVER, RONALDO.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> AARON!
PLEASE!
WE NEED HEADLINES!
>> YOU GUYS ARE PATHETIC.
YOU?
>> AARON, THIS IS TYGOB.
DID YOU CONSULT WITH BRETT FAVRE
BEFORE THE SEASON STARTED?
>> INTERESTING QUESTION.
YEAH.
LET'S JUST SAY ME AND BRETT --
BRETT DOESN'T EXACTLY LOVE THE
OLD A-ROD.
YOU KNOW, AFTER WHAT I KIND OF
DID WHAT JORDAN LOVE IS TRYING
TO DO TO ME TO HIM.
WE DID HAVE ONE FAIRLY
INTERESTING CONVERSATION WHERE
BASICALLY I JUST ASKED HIM, YOU
KNOW, WAS PLAYING FOR THE
VIKINGS THAT BAD?
WAS IT AS BAD AS IT SEEMS?
DO YOU THINK I COULD GET AWAY
WITH THAT IF KIRK GOES ONE WAY
THIS YEAR?
BRETT -- WE SAID THINGS IN
CONFIDENCE TO EACH OTHER AS
QUARTERBACKS.
ULTIMATELY HE GAVE ME SOME GOOD
ADVICE, WHICH WAS DON'T -- DO
NOT GO TO THE JETS, NO MATTER
WHAT.
I DID APPRECIATE THAT.
REALLY, WE JUST TALKED ABOUT HOW
MUCH WE LOVE GREEN BAY AND HOW
WE'RE PACKERS FOREVER AND ALL
THAT GARBAGE.
I HAVE TIME FOR ONE MORE
QUESTION.
>> AARON!
>> YOU.
>> AARON, THIS IS STINK CHILLI.
I WAS CURIOUS IF YOU THOUGHT
MYLES TELLER WOULD BE BETTER FOR
"LA LA LAND."
>> MILES IS A PERSONAL CLOSE
FRIEND OF MINE.
HE'S BEEN ON THESE MOVIES WITH
MY FIANCEE.
RYAN GOSLING WAS FINE IN THAT
MOVIE.
HAD A NATURAL CHARM.
I THINK THAT MOVIE WAS MISSING
THE WHOLE GRUFF EAGLES FAN WHO
YELLS AT YOU AT A BAR THING THAT
MYLES TELLER WOULD HAVE ADDED TO
THAT MOVIE.
MILES IS A GREAT ACTOR.
YOU KNOW, I LOVED HIM IN
"SPECTACULAR NOW" AND THE
DIVERSION MOVIES AND FALLING
STARS WITH MY FIANCEE -- WHAT IS
THAT?
THAT WAS ANSEL ELGART?
THAT WASN'T MYLES TELLER?
I HAVE TO TALK TO SHALENE ABOUT
THAT.
THOSE GUYS LOOK THE EXACT SAME
TO ME.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT IS IT FOR ME.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR REALLY,
REALLY DUMB QUESTIONS.
WE'RE NOT PLAYING THE LIONS
UNTIL MONDAY NIGHT.
I'LL CHILL UNTIL SATURDAY.
PLAY ONE CATCH WITH RANDALL COBB
AND CALL IT A PRACTICE.
LATER.
>> AARON!
AARON!
♪